في هجوم انتحاري استهدف مكتبه في مدينه
مزار شريف عاصمه ولايه بلخ شمال افغانستان
يعتقد ان من يقف خلفه تنظيم داعش خرسان
قتل حاكم ولايه بلخ داوود مزمل واثنان من
مرافقيه وتعود تفاصيل العمليه الانتحاريه
الى دخول شخص يعمل في مقر الولايه وهو
يرتدي ستره مليئه بمواد متفجره فجر نفسه
في المبنى كانت هناك مخاوف من ان العمليه
تستهدف نائب رئيس الوزراء للشؤون
الاقتصاديه مولى عبد الغني برادر الذي كان
موجودا سابقا في المبنى لكنه لم يكن هناك
وقت التفجير حركه طالبان ياتي على راسها
الملا هبه طل اخون زاده وهو زعيمها ومن
حيث القوه ياتي بعده الملا عبد الغني
برادر الذي كان نائبه السابق واصبح نائبا
لرئيس الوزراء بعد سيطره طالبان على
افغانستان اما رئيس الوزراء الملا محمد
حسن اخوند الذي تولى كونه رئيس شورى
الحركه تنظيم داعش خراسان ظهر في يناير
عام 2015 في ولايه ننجرهار شرقي افغانستان
وهو يتكون من قيادات ومقاتلين من حركه
طالبان الافغانيه وطالبان الباكستانيه
وكانت اماكن وجود التنظيم في الولايات
الشرقيه لافغانستان منها نيجر هار وكونار
ونورستان وفي اعقاب سيطره طالبان على
البلاد قام التنظيم بتغيير استراتيجيته
بالانتقال الى الولايات الشماليه خاصه في
بدخشان وتخار وقندوز وبلخا نظرا لضعف
سيطره طالبان عليها وحتى في العاصمه كابول
والتي توجد فيها قيادات التنظيم قوه داعش
في افغانستان تقدر بثلاثه الاف عنصر وفق
تقرير للامم المتحده الا ان منظمه معاهده
الامن الجماعي قد درت عددهم بضعف هذا
العددتنا على معرفه بما يحدث في افغانستان
منذ سقوط الحكومه لكن لا تزال لدينا بعض
القدره على ذلك وبناء على ما نعرفه بشان
تهديد القاعده هم يحاولون النجاح ولا خطط
لديهم للهجوم على الغرب قريبا نعتقد ان
تنظيم داعش هناك يشكل تهديدا اكبر هم
يتعرضون للهجوم من نظام طالبان الان وهي
مساله وقت قبل ان يكون لديه القدره على
مهاجمتنا
وفي تقرير استخباراتي حذر الطالبان من ان
داعش يخطط للدخول الى شرق افغانستان لتكون
قاعده انطلاقهم لباقي البلاد